Johnny's mother had three children the  first child was named April the second  child was named May what was the third  child's name Johnny because it was  Johnny's mother what word in the English  language is always felt incorrectly  incorrectly how much dirt is there in a  hole that measures two units by three  units by four units  none because it's a hole Billy was born  on December 28th yet her birthday always  falls in the summer how is this possible  she lives in the southern hemisphere  good I might in British Columbia you  cannot take a picture of a man with a  wooden leg why not you need a camera not  a wooden leg er if you are running a  race and you pass the person in second  place what place would you be in now  second place a clerk at a butcher shop  stands five feet ten inches tall and  wears size 13 sneakers what does he  weigh meat so how did you do leave your  score in the comments and don't forget  to subscribe